je m'appelle claude collin je suis
président du club d'échecs de courtenay
j'ai 88 ans
bonjour et bienvenue au club d'échecs de
pour sonner genève et vous expliquer un
peu comment ça se passe vous avez
l'occasion de voir et de découvrir les
écrits
un échiquier ce n'est pas d'alliés n'y a
pas le même nombre de 15,8 sur les
figues et 10 sur le damier donc sur les
chèques on utilise états blanche et des
cas soir quand vous voyez des pièces par
tout
ce que j'ai fait pour manger
c'était le but c'est toujours les
embêter son bon temps de mettre en échec
moi je suis joueur d'échecs depuis très
longtemps ça fait plus 50 ans
donc j'ai aussi ma priorité c'est de
promouvoir les échecs et rendez effet
accessible au plus grand nombre
en gardant l'aspect loisir donc je suis
pas mon premier coup d'essai j'ai déjà
monté une dizaine de clubs dans
différents secteurs
voilà une partie d'un blitz entre le
plus fort joueur du club et l'avenir
jean-philippe un des lots de plus de
ville et puis notre avenir un vélo de
1200 mais qui va pas rester à sept lots
là il va progresser
le jury bat jean philippe ses champagnes
payer pariant fier
à bourgeois d'échec à une notion de
visibilité de la partie d'un as lease de
prévoir prévoir les coûts le plus loin
possible d'être vigilant vais aussi de
garder à mon avis ce qui est très
important une notion de fair play
la essaye dans la khl et chira ce que
j'ai essayé de faire et on voit ça peut
être dangereux pour toi là tu vas la
pauvre elle présentait un échec la loi
oui sauf que en fait si tu peux
reprendre avec ton ful tu vois donc du
coup finalement c'est pas si dangereux
nous déciderons si vous êtes débutant le
mieux ce serait de venir nous voir au
club d'échecs de course mais on a au
sein du club un des animateurs
chevronnés animateurs et animatrices
qui se feront un plaisir de vous faire
progresser vous obliger à progresser
6 et quelle attaque et on souffre
le fond ni pouvais pas bouger sinon le
roi est un échec mais ben ça c'est
encouragent le fou il était cloué
périodiquement jeu jeudi j'arrête tout
je dis que c'est aux autres de commencer
à bosser un peu de promouvoir et
matériaux d'icm en jeu reprend le
collier et puis un crj russe est
justement ce bal danger que si vous
venez au club d'échecs de porte au nez
vous pourrez plus vous passer des échecs
ce sera un succès pour nous